welcome to an episode of
game engine coding quickies
[Music]
today we're going to talk about cameras
and how they're implemented in game
engines and the sort of things
they're designed to handle so let's talk
about cameras real quick if you're
designing a camera
for your game engine what do you need
well look at it real quick well
ultimately you want to handle
uh
a size a rectangle to use a width and a
height
and there's going to be some some
vectors that you can cache if you want
cache just means basically save them
temporarily
and you sort of might as well
so these will be like normalized front
up right
and you're gonna have a position that's
also quite important now if you're in
perspective you're gonna have a field
view
and this is basically your eyes
how wide it looks out or how narrow you
can also use this as a
zoom or scoping or scouting or whatever
you might want in your game
with cool little utilities the yaw
is
left and right turning
and the pitch is up and down
you can do these in radians
or
whatever the 360
however you want to do it but you got to
make sure you get your translations
right
and a render distance is
something you set on your
projection matrix
so that you know how much stuff to
render so this the camera is going to
tie in with rendering
a view matrix is basically determines
where you're looking and what you can
see along with the projection
so
you don't need to update these you don't
ever set these on their own typically
typically these are calculated
off of these other variables that you've
set
so you can cache them once they've been
updated
so there's also a skybox that you can
render per camera i think this is a
decent
idea and here are some update functions
now basically these will update
the projection and b matrix
so
it's up to you how you want to do these
but typically what i do is i have some
has the view changed has the projection
change
so any time
now this is actually a poorly designed
class i need to update some things but
basically whenever the view or
projection changes
we want to update anything that's cached
is the idea here that's mainly done
actually through this shader tick
because it updates it onto our shader if
they've changed so anything we really
need to do is make sure any time we call
i believe any of these functions
this one
update camera vectors updates the front
up and right so that's not something we
change
so in a more perfect world
these would all be private
and we would have getters and setters
for them that automatically toggle these
update projection change but i have done
that
through these functions
anytime they're called we update the
view matrix
we need to update what's cached on the
shader so this one is a very manually
controlled setup where the end user has
to
call these when appropriate so after you
change something you need to call these
and that's going to turn up the the
shader but you need to call the shader
take two and it'll update
anything on the shaders
so that's one way of doing it
um but now
this whole class here is somewhat
subjective you can do it your own way
but ultimately you need to get these
right for your
the rendering you want to do so how do
you determine which camera you're
viewing from how do you switch cameras
and that's something i told them for a
while and i like the way unity does it
so we're going to look at that
i don't have it implemented in this
class but the way unity does it
is they have a depth
and we're just going to call this in
depth
now i'm not planning on
implementing this
structure right now because i i'd have
to do a whole bunch more
but basically what unity does is it
takes
the one with the highest depth and
renders it on top kind of like render
layers
so what you can do
in unity is you can make a
small viewport
put it in the center
and
do like a
rear view mirror or you can do a mini
map or something with a different camera
it's and you can just have
the top layer camera as the highest
depth
so that's how you do it
in that way you could also if you're
doing your own custom thing maybe you
say hey we only support one or two
cameras maybe we only support one and
you just gotta switch to the one you're
using
through some mechanism or some system
that's another way i think depth is one
of the coolest ways
and it's something i probably want to
implement into my engine eventually
so that's cameras in a nutshell let me
know what you want to hear about next in
the next
game engine quickie video peace out guys
you